I'm true Thank You professor Ammann at
four
giving me the pleasure of inviting you
all to Professor Subramanian second talk
in our exciting Yasir lecture series
yesterday we discussed the idea of
mobility and I think today we're going
to be continuing with that theme of
connected early modern histories but
looking at it through the lens of
particular figures and agents quite
different in many ways from what we
discussed yesterday of course I think
it's important before we start to again
you know be reminded of the fact that
Professor Subramanyam of course has been
not only doing history in a way that
engages India and Iran for those of us
who work on it but also Europe and I
think that's where we're shifting a
little bit today as well not just what
we do in history in terms or any
modernity but also how we do it and it's
been a model for many of us going
through the ranks and whether we're
doing art history or intellectual
history poetry and so on and his work
has really been instrumental to many of
us I think you mentioned in jolbon
yesterday which I really appreciated
that somebody who works on this a
service but I know you've worked closely
with Jamel Quezada and Bert Frogner
and all of these figures who've been
really thinking about dispersion eight
world as a connected world and I'm
excited that you've broadened it even
further
more recently in your work and I'm
reminded of course in the way in which
you use these micro histories and a
textured manner not unlike our Logan's
burg and others to really understand the
words which they inhabited and to really
give life to it in a way that I think is
just really remarkable and and we're all
very thankful for that one of these
figures of course that you're going to
discuss and I'm very excited about is
your own Xavier and the Jesuits who was
a missionary and came to the course of
Abbas excuse me up where and John here
and a really important figure not only
for the text that he wrote but I hope
you talk about the paintings the
Illustrated
and I'm very very excited about this so
thank you for being here with us and I
won't hold up the stage thank you okay
thank you so today my intentions to
shift somewhat geographically but also
thematically so the focus will move
somewhat out of the deccan which is
where we were largely yesterday to
another axis which is much more northern
Indian axis having more to do with the
with the Indian theme originals and
thematically I say that broadly I'm
going to shift to something which should
be more of a discussion in the nature of
a kind of intellectual history actually
now this set of reflections centers
around something which will be familiar
certainly to some of you and hopefully
if it is not will be so at the end of
this hour which is the so-called
mirror for princess which is a genre
which was very widespread known across a
good part of the Eurasian world known
certainly in the Christian world known
certainly through the Islamic world and
perhaps even even further afield the
argument can indeed be made that you can
find it even in parts of Asia which
where the courts not were not Islamic in
their orientation such as some of the
courts of southern India or Sri Lanka
and so on so the the mirror for princess
pushed in spiegel for those of you who
like to say it fancily these are these
are of course somewhat mythic in a
certain sense in their in their origin
so for example many of the stories about
how this genre itself came about tell us
of course that this is the original
occasion for the creation of such a
mirror for princess which is of course
when Aristotle gave advice to Alexander
Aristotle give an advice to Alexander
concerning what it was to be a good king
what it was to be a just king and of
course since as we know both Aristotle
and Alexander continue to be revered
figures not merely in the Christian
tradition but minor in a much much wider
sense I mean I will remind you of the
very large production in the last few
years even of my colleague in Paris
Pierre Brio concerning the whole cycle
of Alexander materials going all the way
actually through his recent book which
just came out from Harvard the first
European actually shows how Alexander
was instrumentalized by Europeans in the
18th century to justify their projects
of empire but he's also shown of course
what Alexander was in relation for
example to the X minutes and and others
and we know that he was a figure who was
certainly tremendously important in
various parts of India southern India
northern India and indeed we know in
Bengali in the 17th century there is
quite an interesting set of materials
relating to the second Annamma
Chandra for example written by the
Bengali poet from Eric on allow now this
set of materials regarding mirrors
mirrors for princes has been the subject
of quite considerable literature amongst
analysts of the Islamic world I give you
just two examples of them the book on
the right that you see over here advice
for the salon which focuses much more on
the medieval period concerns amongst
other things materials in Arabic but
also relating to the Seljuks and others
who in a way gave us the kind of
prototypical works which were referred
to later on nizam al-mulk but also what
is referred to
which comes down to the muggles as the
tradition of what is sometimes called
nazarian ethics and my very good friend
and collaborator was a fur alum of
course has written also quite
extensively about this in this book
in fact the paper which I'm presenting
the election presenting today is is in
large measure the product of joint
research done lit with Lucifer alum now
in this work of the fur alum published
about a decade or more ago he actually
focuses on what he calls the texts
concerning o'clock o'clock in ohms and
he actually suggests that this was a
very powerful set of materials for a
number of reasons but one of the things
that he actually puts his finger on was
the idea that in a way the problem of
justice could be separated from the
problem of religion and how and why
could the problem of justice be
separated from the problem of religion
the simplest way of looking at it would
be to say that when in the mongol world
muslim writers were engaging with the
king is a tradition the question which
they have to face up to and they began
facing up to it already before the
setting up of the Ilhan at dispensation
but certainly during the alternate
dispensation the point was in some sense
could a non muslim ruler be a just ruler
this is not a anodyne question because
it was a question basically for instance
of evaluating someone like Chinggis
Khaan was he or was he not a just ruler
despite the fact that he was not a
muslim and indeed they therefore look to
the fact that going back to antiquity we
had a situation and in a certain sense
of course this is exactly the same
situation as that which is faced by
medieval christian theologians when they
are asked the question did aristotle and
plato go to hell after all they were not
Christians so in a certain sense the
question which arises over
is good the justice of a ruler be
separated from the question of whether
he was or was not a Muslim and one of
the things that muzaffer alum actually
tried to show was how very creatively
some of the writers in the hockey
tradition coming out of Central Asia
coming out of the simulated dispensation
and especially at this very interesting
Felkel moment which we know quite a lot
about but which still remains fully to
be researched which is the core of Herat
at the close of the 15th century in the
early 16th century at this moment the
question of how one could separate
justice adlet from from religion and one
of the ways in which they actually did
it which he tries to show is for
instance very creatively extending even
the idea of what the Sharia was to say
that the Sharia is not what one
literally thinks of but it is in fact
any form of rules which allow you to
prosecute the business of good
governance which is of course from a
certain point of view an extremely
dangerous thing to say now of course the
Mughals then came into northern India a
bit this baggage with them so they
already had this set of reflections
which had come out of the art of Khmers
own court then from the timber route
courts then from certain have sent
Becker as caught in in Herat and in fact
when I said when they brought this
baggage sometimes they brought it quite
literally alright so for instance a very
famous text from the Herod court was
they occurring to my uni and it was
actually brought into and slightly
modified in in adverse court other texts
survived
these include of course those famous
sort of animal fable type texts which
were which Abbas our monarch for
instance mentioned yesterday the Khalil
of Adam now but there are also others
which broadly from the same family which
were often taken again to be advice
literature which know the animal fables
very
superficial disguise for a waters
actually political wisdom which was
being which was being dispensed now in
the court of Akbar of course we know
that a place was kept for argument which
was argument on the matter of Austin
Sibley religion but it was actually a
place just kept for discussion in
general but this is probably the
deliberate revival of an of a Mongol
tradition if those of you who have of
course read the famous travel account of
Geum the rubric who was sent to to the
Mongol court in Karakoram would recall
his famous incident when Guillaume is
presented with others with whom he
debates so these include Eastern
Christians
these include Tibetan and other Buddhist
religious figures he of course claims as
everybody always claims that he won all
the debates but we know that there was a
kind of a tradition of such debate where
the the ruler was present and somehow
mediated and sometimes took decisions on
who was doing well and who was not doing
so so this is the kind of tradition that
we have which is carried over into the
Mughal Court and in this tradition there
are oral arguments but there are also
texts which are brought different texts
were brought to bear of course we know
famously that a a bird claimed that he
couldn't read this was probably a
strategic play but at any rate he
claimed he could not read so all the
text had to be presented to him orally
and so even when text for example the
Jesuits whom you see present in this in
this painting on the Left these are
probably two of the Jesuits from the
first mission which means they are
probably result for aqua diva and either
Montserrat or Franciscan trickers but
these Jesuits in fact we know they
brought him the plantain Bible which was
put away into the into the Mogul library
so these materials were also brought in
terms of allowing for
arguments we made arguments regarding as
I said religious matters were also very
wide-ranging arguments concerning all
kinds of other things for instance we
know that that the Jesuits talked to
upward concerning the Portuguese rulers
of the time and they presented to Albert
for instance the figure of the
Portuguese ruler who had been killed in
1578 in a rather tragic tragic light so
the presence of these Jesuits then added
a dimension just as in the 17th century
Safavid court later on the presence of
other Catholic priests would would have
a role of some interest in significance
the distribution is slightly different
in the Safavid case the presence tends
to be much more of augustinians and in
particular of Carmelites the most famous
of whom is arguably pare Rafael do more
in the middle decades of the 17th
century but you can see over here this
is actually a late painting as the
painting from the from one of the
Johnson albums from from probably
therefore the the early 18th century you
can still see here the Jesuits much less
stylized manner much more chaotic and
and playful presentation of the court
that you can that you can see over here
now this Jesuit presence of course then
continued it continued into the reign of
the next monarch Jahangir who ruled from
1652 1627 you can see over here
one little jesuit figure who stands out
you can see him probably somewhat better
than the enlarged version this is very
probably the Florentine Jesuit Francesco
Corsi and ah this moment the moment of
Jahangir it is particularly interesting
for us because we have a rich collection
of Jesuit materials and letters
describing their activities in the
interactions of the mughal court and
what they did there but what is actually
really really remarkable for us is that
now we have actually account
account of this coming from the Mughal
Court itself right so we are no longer
dependent on the Jesuits to tell us what
they what actually happen and we are no
longer purely dependent on the kind of
reading against the grain strategy with
someone like Carlo Ginsburg once
presented in a known SAF is called alien
voices where he suggested that there are
cracks in the Jesuit text and you can
actually see things which the Jesuits
don't even understand they're saying
sometimes in their own text but what we
actually have in the Mogul case which is
really interesting is it texts witches
which actually gives us then the
possibility of juxtaposing the Jesuit
point of view with with the the other
point of view this of course goes
together the representation which we
have in a number of modal paintings of
individual Jesuits the there's a
certainly at least a handful of them
sometimes it's difficult to identify who
exactly they were because of the fact
that we don't actually have other
materials which allow us to to get a
clear clear sense of them this is again
a clearly one of the Jesuits who was
present in the court in the 16 10s or
1620s I believe that it is today in the
Walter's Museum in Baltimore okay now
let me shift my focus now in 1527 the
year that niccolò machiavelli
died in florence the portuguese of
course had been in the indian ocean for
about thirty years right and in the 30
years that they'd been there
they had already acquired a quiet
unsavory reputation they first came into
contact with the Mughals probably in the
1540s sort of late 15 thirties at the
time when Humayun was around Gujarat
briefly but this in fact didn't have
much of a consequence we had to wait
till the 1570s for the models to
actually have proper dealings with
Portugese and when the portuguese came
to have regular dealings with them which
actually happened to be true the Jesuits
who were sent to the Mughal Court one of
the difficulties that the Jesuits had
was that as they were in a situation
where they were somehow required to
explain the functioning of the
Portuguese Empire and what the norms and
manners of actually practicing
statecraft in that Empire were right now
obviously they were not going to tell
the models to read Machiavelli right but
in fact you see in a minute that it's
not quite so obvious as that and in fact
it's an interesting question and so the
question which has been somewhat debated
what the text of Machiavelli had to do
with Iberian empire building at that at
that time right so consider these two
great figures of Iberian empire building
of the early sixteenth century
regarding the one on the Left around the
Cortes John Eliot has has written in a
very famous essay I quote that Cortes
had an attitude to fortune fortune with
a capital F Fortuna not unlike that of
Machiavelli and further he knew that the
man who aspired to master fortune must
possess innate qualities of
resourcefulness and guile those
qualities which for Machiavelli helped
to constitute with - he then proceeds in
this essay to show how if you actually
analyze the letters of Cortes you can
actually find very many tropes which are
similar to the Machiavellian tropes but
then subsequent authors have also
pointed out that this actually really
reflects the fact that both of them were
drawing upon a common fund of resources
it's not actually as if there was any
kind of textual contamination between
between the one and the other in the
case of the figure that you see on the
right who is often sometimes equated
with Cortes which is the governor of
France Delta calque governor of
Portuguese India from 1509 to 1564
chi-chi's historian Angela
where she actually shows or she argues
that there are points of convergence
between Machiavelli and Alba camp in
relation to such themes as the
connection between force and political
reputation the best methods of conquest
and so on and so forth but then she
again argues that of course this proves
nothing in terms of an actual influence
or an actual termination now where do
the the strongest convergences apply if
you actually read Albuquerque letters
and they're very large corpus of his
letters one of the interesting words
that he likes to use and he uses many
times is the word dissimilar to
dissimulate and so for example he uses
it be in the verb form he uses it in the
noun form for but he also uses it in
very interesting in very interesting
ways for instance he talks about how one
of the things that he did was when he
was facing difficulties with the rulers
of Calicut in Kerala he persuaded one of
the members of their family to poison
the ruler and then he says that I'm
certain that so-and-so kills the sama
three with poison because in all my
letters I wrote to him that he should
poison him and I would come to peace to
it and after to an agreement and he
calls this as sometimes he talks about
it as in relation to try some but he
also talks about it in terms of
dissimilar but then he says and this is
interesting justification he says that
the reason why we are obliged to do this
is this is basically how Muslims act
that says they dissimulate we are
obliged to dissimulate right so in a
world of de simulators the man who does
not dissimulate as a fool so the
justification here then which recurs
time and again had become so well known
right that by the middle decades of the
16th century it's actually a completely
thematized in Indian descriptions of the
activities of the Portuguese I'll give
you two examples of this the most famous
example of course is the
famous story repeated a number of Indian
texts which is actually strangely enough
a story taken out of they need right
which is the story of the foundation of
Carthage where the Portuguese go and ask
someone for a piece of territory and he
says you can have a piece of territory
as large as the skin of an animal but
then what they do is to take the skin of
the animal and they make it into a long
thread and then they use that thread to
actually define the circumference of the
space which they now claim they can have
because it is the size of the skin of
the animal and this is where they then
build the fortress and this is for
example how they take malacca or how
they take view and so on and so forth so
this has become a regular theme
concerning their duplicity similarly if
you look at a quite well-known arabic
text written against the portuguese in
the 1570s called the fertile mujahedeen
sieve as a valid protocol in in in
Kerala it repeats again and again this
this thematic of the dis simulation of
the of the Portuguese so this was a team
then which the Jesuits knew and which
they were embarrassed by the earliest
Jesuit let me remind you of course who
came to Asia the first generation of
them came in 1542 right so these four
Jesuits who accompanied the governor
Marty muffins of the saucer and the most
famous of that first batch of Jesuits of
course was Francis Xavier right and this
is his rough itinerary as you can see
over here he comes and spends time in
western India in southern India and
Southeast Asia goes to Japan and of
course then famously dies in a shipwreck
of the sea of China and then of course
his bodies miraculously discovered
intact and brought back to Goa where
apparently it is still miraculously
intact you can inspect it - a couple of
toes which were bitten off by someone
when it was taken out in procession now
this if you read the letters of Xavier
Xavier for example is consistently aware
of the bad reputation of the Portuguese
and he talks about
how does the fact is famous letter which
he writes to someone saying do not send
your relatives to Asia because what do
we do over here he says we just we just
know how to conjugate the verb to rob
rap is rap yo and so on and so forth so
this is this is all that we do we rob
people and we pretend we are doing good
things but in fact we are the most
immoral of people right so this is
something which is already present in
some sense inside of the jesuit
discourse much before in fact a good 25
or 30 years before they made it to the
mughal cook now when the desert is
actually made it to the mughal court
therefore he was fighting an uphill
battle right so they were representing a
religion to be sure but they were also
representing a secular power which was
widely thought to be untrustworthy and
widely thought to be characterized by
this kind of constant duplicity and lack
of trustworthiness lack of capacity to
keep one's would the Jesuits of course
had various options so the first lot of
Jesuits we know did not bother really to
get very far in terms of understanding
the Persian language the function
through intermediaries they had some
armenian intermediaries the famous
Marisol Kernan but they also had others
who who they they they managed to to
convert into sub serve them in this in
this in this way but in the next lot of
Jesuits who came after that first
generation in the 1590s decided that
they would actually invest in learning
Russian now why were they interested in
learning Persian right so this is for
what you see on the left is the first
lot of Jesuits this is a generation of
montserrat right the catalan Jesuit who
wrote a very interesting account of the
Mughals but who clearly didn't know any
Indian languages or Persian but then the
second generation of Jesuits who came
included this figure who's a figure who
will play something of a role in what
follows a man by the name of Jerome
Sevilla that's not his real name is
really mother animal Herodias panetta a
goonie
but he was the maternal nephew of Xavier
and so he took his metal uncle's name
because it was obviously a prestigious
name by this time now
Xavier Xavier by the time he came to the
Mughal Court was already middle-aged he
had studied in Spain and he had studied
in Portugal in the 1560s and 1570s he
was not considered to be a particularly
talented or intelligent individual if
you compare him with let's say people of
his general generation someone like the
Italian Matteo Ricci or the other
Italian vkalira Giri who were both sent
to China were considered to be vastly
superior intellectual figures to someone
like like like Xavier but Savior
eventually one way or another did manage
to make his way to the mughal court he
was roughly I think 45 or 46 when he
reached the Mughal Court and he and his
companions then began to learn partial
why well their initial idea was that
they would actually produce materials in
Persian for the consumption of the
mughal court so the materials in persian
that they wanted to produce were
essentially religious in nature so you
see here for instance this is the death
policy and these texts were meant to
actually give the Mughals the
quote-unquote authentic version of the
Christian scriptures and the christian
the christian materials the mongols of
course already had extinct translations
of christian materials which had come to
them often through greek and so on
but the the Jesuits did not actually
like them to use those materials they
preferred that these other materials
should be should be put in their place
and indeed amongst these materials
perhaps the most successful was these
texts called the marital codes
successful in the sense that it's one of
the few things which seems to attracted
the mothers enough that they actually
produced painting
and programmatic materials around it and
here you can see a quite nice addition
off this text to the translation by
wheeler Saxton which came out a few a
few years ago we have several as I said
Ellis traited copies of it including one
in in Lahore as well as others in the
United States so these texts were meant
for the Jesuits to explain their
religion to the Nagas but of course they
had very unexpected consequences now
here's one of the unexpected
consequences these Jesuit materials
eventually fell in the hands of the
Dutch right and this was one of the
earliest actually printed texts in
Persian that one can find perhaps even
the earliest printed book in Persian
actually it's the the again the Dostana
mercy but it's a very curious text
because actually what it was was it's
published in in the Netherlands it has
it's a bilingual edition so it has the
Persian text produced ostensibly by
Xavier but actually we see it's more
complicated than that then it has a back
translation installation into Latin Rite
gun by this man called note awake to do
who was a Protestant polemicist
and if you actually read the text those
of you who read Persian will notice what
it says on top of it all right which
says that Solomon Alou there and in fact
it actually says this in a different
fashion in the Latin text or there it
says see multi-multi Moses contaminator
mmm why is it contaminated because it
basically Ludovic deduce point is that
this is actually a set of old wives
tales this is not really Christian
material and what this man has done is
not merely taken materials from the
Gospels or other things he's added all
kinds of stuff to it which actually has
no legitimacy in the Christian tradition
and in fact he also did the same thing
with another text
which he also published at roughly the
same time which is called the Spanish
San Pedro there's a story of sent sent
Peter again presented in exactly the
same fashion citizen and an unexpected a
negative negative consequence of course
there is a much larger negative
consequence which we learn by reading
not the Jesuit materials but by reading
this other text which I've already
mentioned to you which is the counter
text and this is the text which is
written by a man who for a long time
remained in the shadows but who now has
become it's become clear to us was
really much more important than we ever
thought he was and this is someone
called mallanna abdul Sattar of the
sitar even Kassim Lahori and he is
someone who appears in in every Persian
text of Xavier he usually appears
towards the end in the coliforms
sometimes he appears a little bit in the
beginning and so on and if you read the
standard Jesuit versions of it including
modern Jesuit authors they will always
say he was a little helper who did a
little bit of work for Xavier that's the
kind of impression that he gives us but
actually turns out that he was a much
more substantial figure and the way that
we can actually understand what a
substantial figure he was was by looking
at several of his own texts but notably
this text which has very recently come
to light and being published under the
title it's a modern title of majolica
jahangiri where it's it discusses the
the Knightly discussion so it says that
it's not the rosen armchair
it's not that what happened during the
day which is what the emperor wrote in
his own diary
it's the Shabnam chair it's what
happened in the night when the emperor
had informal discussions and if you read
that text
what of the citta tells us is that the
Jesuits regularly came and regularly
presented their arguments and were
regularly reduced to mincemeat in the
court that they were actually made fun
of they were actually mocked in various
kinds of ways even though they of course
deployed their own mockery against
some Muslim traditions now this mockery
often was fairly crude it's of the type
that you find for instance even 19th
century debates between Christian
missionaries and Muslims in different
parts of the Islamic world but the
mockery in fact took on a very different
flavor at a certain point when of the
sitar himself turned against the Jesuits
and once he turned against the Jesuits
he actually was able to deploy a very
profound knowledge of everything with
the Jesuits had taught him in order for
him to be helped able to help them do
their translations okay and so he
preceded them to make fun of them at an
extreme level of detail saying all kinds
of very peculiar things I would just
give you one example which is at some
point there was a discussion of the
famous Noli Me Tangere episode right
which is the moment when Christ is
resurrected he returns he's in the
garden he sees Mary Magdalene and then
she approaches him and she says - don't
touch me and he's suffused with light so
there's a discussion of this episode and
when the story is recounted somebody in
the court says mockingly why didn't she
recognize him I mean he hadn't been dead
a long time honey so he says well they
didn't recognize him because he was
suffused in light so then of the sitar
who of course knew this text very well
said but didn't you just tell us that
she in fact thought he was a gardener he
was the bath bomb and he says yes sir
she thought he was the gardener so it's
very common in where you come from for
gardeners to be suffused in light is it
how does it have you written sighs these
different parts of the story which don't
seem to really add up as a as a
narrative so he's actually picking his
way through the little details of it you
know mocking them at at at every point
now why is up the sitar interesting for
us he's interesting for us not only
because of the question of how he first
helps the Jesuits and then turns against
them and then uses the materials that he
knows to mock them but for an earlier
moment and it's to this moment that I
will turn this was the moment when
the Jesuits are asked by Jahangir now to
step aside for a moment from this whole
set of proselytizing and missionary
materials which they're trying to
produce and instead produce something
else for him which is a mirror of
princess texts right now I will open and
close a very quick parenthesis here by
the way those those other materials
which they produced these missionary
materials also had a had another very
bizarre afterlife because some of these
materials were taken to Iran and then
polemical texts were written against
them in Iran in the 17th century
those pala mix were taken to Rome where
counter polemics were written in Rome by
by Christian missionaries they were then
brought back to Iran in the end of the
17th century Augustinian was converted
to Islam called awake holy Jesus LOM
then wrote even a further counter
polemic to the so you can see that the
sin of Jesuit materials of xavier had a
had a whole life of their own but let's
come back to this this is the moment
then when Jahangir in his court says to
them why don't you produce a text about
how Kings good Kings are supposed to
rule in your part of the world rather
than spending all your time telling us
these pious stories about you know the
Saints and the life of Jesus Christ and
so on and we know that Xavier accepted
this challenge but of course he was not
capable of writing this text himself
right as indeed we know if we start
looking at any of these texts in detail
you begin to become very suspicious
because these texts often have a level
of rhetorical polish and a depth of
references and cultural references which
suggest that actually Xavier could not
have been capable of writing them on his
own so in fact all of these texts are
co-authored texts and let me also add a
last point here which is that after of
the citta fell out with the Jesuits
Xavier's Persian production stops there
is no more Persian production right
which is a very very simple and telling
fact now what is the text that he then
decided to produce so this is the the
text that he decided to produce
it's called directorial those rights
manual for Kings and this is how it goes
it says some manual for Kings in which
is treated how a king should behave in
his government composed by the father
Geronimo Xavier of the company of Jesus
addressed to the great king Jahangir
great mogul done in the year of our Lord
1609 so 1609 1610 is about the end of
the collaboration with Satar it has four
chapters the first deals with how the
king should deal with God the second how
we should deal with themselves
the third how you should deal with his
Grandy's and officials and the fourth
how he should deal with his people so
this is the the summaries in in in
Spanish of a like a Portuguese mixed
Spanish but then the text itself of
course is meant a lean persons there are
two manuscripts of it that exist the
first manuscript is called in Persian is
called other was Sultanate and the two
manuscripts that exist this is the the
Rome manuscript which is one he sent to
the general of the Jesuits and there is
a second manuscript which was brought
back to by the traveler Giambattista the
Quixote and eventually wound up in
London now in this text the when when
Xavier was producing it he may not have
known but of the Satar certainly knew
that he was presenting this to a court
which already had a library of such
mirror of princes literature right so I
mean of the citta certainly knew that
the of the existence of whether it was a
clock in our city or the see a certain
Lama or the o'clock a whom I uni and so
on and so forth there were even three or
four texts we know which are produced
for Jahangir himself the more is more is
there Jahangir is slightly later than
this but there are there is a applied
Jahangir E which is a reworked version
of a text from Kabul in the end of the
sixteenth century so he's he's aware of
this of this of this fact and
furthermore he's aware of the fact that
when you're writing this text you cannot
actually fill it with Christian
references alright so this text has to
in a way step back from the Christian
context and try to present the whole
problem
skinship as a problem which is not the
problem of necessarily a crystal so how
does he do this he does this essentially
by working his way through some general
propositions but then actually the whole
text is constructed around exemplar and
anecdotes specific stories and we see
how these stories work okay so here's
how the the the text begins it says
roughly and the early early I'm reading
from one of the early sections hmm but
it does have the standard by the way
bismillah invocation which by the way is
a via sometimes in the Christian text
doesn't use some of them in the
Christian text would say in the name of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
one God
whereas here he doesn't he doesn't do
that right so it says it's a beautiful
duty to thank the governor of the world
before whose threshold had added three
rulers increase the fortune and capital
of their grandeur and Majesty by
offering a base obeisance it is
astonishing subhana Allah that even a
stranger and humbled dervish who has no
interest in the world's affairs can
presume to place the regulations of
Empire and the laws of of rulership the
rabbit in a hella far vaca Venini farm
on D he and for such a ruler of the
world who with the help of God's grace
and account of the support of his high
fortune has come to know the secrets of
conquest and governance etc a very high
and nicely highfalutin language which
clearly someone like citta can can can
control now let me get very quickly to
what the materials are that he is now
going to use and it's actually
interesting where he will go for his his
his examples right so as I said he
cannot go to the usual places he cannot
go to the habitual places which inhabit
the texts that he's already written like
the miracle codes or whatever it is he
has to go he has to go in a sense
elsewhere he has to step away from the
religious context and move then to
another another
the set of materials materials which
from time to time will be familiar to
people in this court remember this is a
very cosmopolitan Court remember that
this is a court that has present in it
people from Central Asia present a good
number of Iranians has people from the
former Ottoman domains so it has a fair
diversity of people but it has only
really a small handful of Europeans who
are who are there so where does he go
well interestingly one place he goes is
Roman history so there are actually a
whole set of materials in the text which
are actually derived from Roman authors
so some of these are clearly
identifiable and it's possible that
Xavier probably had a modest Latin
library at his disposal
so Plutarch Cicero's their faeces and
there's a some some other kinds of
materials which I which I'll come to
from time to time but this as I said a
whole set of stories which are
constantly drawn on Roman materials from
of course a period when the Roman Empire
is not Christian right so for example
there are whole series of anecdotes
which have to do with the figure of
Bocuse - which is of course August's and
similarly there are these these various
stories which concern the Romans and
their and their justice and in fact how
they were actually interested in the
problem of resolving justice again
playing with this whole notion that to
be just is not same as to be of the
correct religion all right so this is a
separation of the problem of justice
from the problem of religious belief
I'll give you an example of of this it's
a very curious story which is actually
the story of of the Roman conquest of
Iberia
he tells the story at great length which
is the story of how the Romans actually
tried to conquer Iberia but they were
resisted by this this general knows who
was described as the cheapest Alaric
pataga
hmm whose name is various historical
figure and how the Romans actually
defeated him using deceit so they made
him promises they seduced him and then
they betrayed him and then he goes on to
make an explanation of this and he says
that when the general who had done this
came back the Roman authorities
reprimanded him and he said you have
brought this land under our control but
you have destroyed our good name and
honor nay Konami Bablu hmm the pride
that we used to have in our truthfulness
has been now transformed into the into
the humiliation of treachery so this is
again timet eyes even the stories from
from a Roman history where it's
suggested that the Romans were proud of
the fact that they did not use treachery
right so which is the the terms that are
used for instance a fur a bodega so
these are the this is the kind of thing
which the Romans disapprove of it even
suggested when when Romans found
themselves in a situation where lands
were taken they would give the lands
back rather than keep them having
acquired them under these wrong wrong
circumstances but then he gets into some
very interesting discussions he says
what is really the difference finally
between treachery and what you could
think of as a pragmatic visit mmm where
you draw the line really between these
kinds of of things isn't it true for
example that we can think of things like
stratagems and trickery heel of a
policeman and on these things all right
and where is the line really to be drawn
between those kinds of things and these
kinds of things and he suggests that in
fact erm very often
one is actually too concerned with the
niceties you actually go you're taking
the line you're taking the road towards
what he calls be Danny Shiva super key
you're going to add stupidity and
humiliation so having said this line
this line which actually has to do with
the idea of honor which has to be
maintained truthfulness which has to be
maintained he begins to play with us how
he constantly plays with it in these
stories concerning Rome in a large
number of stories concerning Iberia and
of course these stories concerning
Iberia are interesting because they
begin with Roman times but then they
continue through the whole Islamic
period in in in Iberia and they
eventually wind up in the 16th century
so there's a whole series of Iberian
stories of which I will come to - one or
two and constantly the the whole
sequence concerns these kinds of of
examples which which talk about how in
fact again there's a thin line between
practical wisdom the wisdom of kings and
the the line which actually goes into
what is duplicity and what is actually
treachery treachery as as such let me
give you just a couple of examples of
this so this is a fairly anodyne story
says the king of portugal Don Sebastian
was going to fight a war in Africa here
first he went to the king of Castile Don
Felipe and requested him to send one of
his experienced general the Duke of Alba
who had won many victories he asked Alba
if he would be willing to go with him on
that war but Alba replied Sahib please
don't ask me this why the king replied
he said you should not take me it so
happens that whenever the Kaiser my
master that's Philip would take me along
to war he knows my nature so he would
hand over the entire charge of the army
to me not only with the army be under my
command even the ruler follows me even
though he knows much about the matters
of war but here we have a different
ruler
and Alba said that he feared that he
would interfere in the matters of war
and since he was not intelligent enough
to know that that that men who are
capable should be left to do their work
he didn't actually want to work for her
I thought this is the whole idea of
notion of a wise ruler who is actually
able to delegate who is actually able to
have subordinates who can function in an
autonomous fashion and unwise rulers who
because of their stupidity are actually
incapable of holding such münster I want
to come to a last story and this story
there's a very large number of these
it's actually constructed on the back of
these these stories which gives us a a
sense of the ambiguity which inhabits
inhabits this text okay it's a curious
story it's a story which actually
concerns the Northeast you can see that
a number of stories concerning these two
rulers john ii who was actually known
for being an extremely ruthless King in
Portugal and Sebastiaan who's normally
taken to be the stupid naive King so the
story is normally tend to vary on these
characterizations of the two Sebastian
was considered to be particularly stupid
because he wouldn't take the advice of
the Jesuits so that was a further black
mark a further black mark against him
and indeed I should mention that the
couple of amusing stories also what what
Columbus which had thrown into this as
well as about Cortes describing how the
conquest of America took place and how
this was done not exactly by treachery
but by by strategizing both by the fact
that Columbus for instance the whole
notion is the story of it actually an
old story about how he he makes holes in
all the ships so that his men can't go
back and therefore they're obliged to
continue into the conquest because they
have no way of actually returning to the
point of origin but the story which I
want to tell to conclude is the story
then as I said of of pole arrow which
you can see that the south of of Madrid
and this story essentially runs like
this
it tells us about the king of Castile
alphonse of the 6th who when he was a
young prince was am obliged to run away
from his father's Kingdom and took
refuge in Toledo which was at that time
ruled over by Ally Moomin the the local
local so far he was treated with great
respect and embraced and so on so forth
and one day he was sleeping in a garden
now the city of Toledo had the
reputation that it was impregnable it
could not be taken and as he was
sleeping the ruler the Saddam was
walking in the gardens along with his
ministers and his the minister said to
him so that can you tell us is it
actually possible to take this city do
you actually know a solution for this
and so fan said yes there is a way and
so he began to explain that there was a
particular way of attacking the defenses
and if the besieging forces had enough
patience and so on that they could
actually do this at this point the
minister spotted this young man sleeping
in a corner and they said wait a minute
this guy's a Christian and you've just
revealed to him the way the secret of of
taking the fortress so the king said no
no he's sleeping let him alone
so this is the others are suspicious
they took some mica they measured it and
dropped it on and then he he was
actually not asleep he pretended to
awake with a start and so they were
satisfied thinking he was actually
asleep and had not heard the secret of
course he then at the end of his term of
exile when back became the king of the
other side came back and used exactly
the secret that he had heard while he
was a guest of the so far in order to
take the city so you can already see
there's some moral ambiguity here over
here but things get get worse things get
worse because in fact that's the famous
of course and Greco I guess of Kalina so
when he was taken to later at the very
last minute because it was turning out
to be very difficult he decided he would
negotiate a
the way I decided he would negotiate is
that he told the Muslims living in the
town that they could remain there as
Muslims he would not convert them and he
would not take away the mosque they
could keep their mosque so they were
left with them was some years passed the
king went off on his campaigns and his
wife who was deeply influenced by the
bishop decided in his absence that she
would take the mosque away and convert
it into a cathedral but she then
proceeded to do now when the king came
back from his campaign the Muslims
complained and said you know you gave us
your word that this mosque would remain
a mosque and look at what you have done
to us right um at which point the king
then threw a fit and he said that he
would punish his wife he he made a big
sort of clamor about it and he called
for his wife to be brought out and
maltreated and so on at which point the
king's daughter went to him and said no
no you can't do this to my mother this
is a public humiliation you know this is
terrible and so on
and she found a way of getting to the
Muslims and told the Muslims that you
may think that you are being very clever
at this point and you're humiliating my
mother but sooner or later we will get
you unless you actually say to the king
that you are willing to withdraw your
request and now the thing has been
converted from a mosque into a church
you are happy to allow it to be a church
presented with these circumstances the
Muslims went to the salon and said
actually we thought about it it was a
place of worship it's still a place of
worship we are willing to legitimate let
matters go now xaviar ends the story on
this extremely ambiguous point right so
here the king who has gained the city
through treachery in a certain sense who
has then proceeded to make a promise to
the Muslim community of this city who
has then not himself broken the promise
that the promise has been broken he has
tried to revert to the situation where
he kept his promise but eventually at
the end
faced with the pressure actually the
Muslims are obliged to give up what had
been promised them simply out of a
situation where they
had to in some sense preserve the skins
in the in the longer term what is left
to wonder what when one had this in the
Mughal Court one one one one made of it
especially given the fact that similar
circumstances perhaps not of the same
communities I want available to the to
the for the mothers to to do to reflect
about at the end of the day therefore
I've often been led to wonder what
exactly
both xavier and sitar were often trying
to convey in this text i started with
this idea that the that clearly the
Jesuits would not have wanted to convey
anything of the Machiavellian to the to
the mothers but either continued to
reflect on the matter I started having
my doubts I started having my doubts on
different rooms first of all I realized
that actually Xavier was educated in
Spain in that brief window when
Machiavelli was not backed I had not yet
been banned hmm he was forced banned in
Portugal and then he was banned in Spain
but there was a brief time when you
could actually read him even in the in
the Indian a Jesuit monastery right so
he belonged to a generation which would
have read Machiavelli did he did he
actually want to leave anything off that
knowledge to the the people whom he was
he was communicating there's one
reference little reference where he says
a famous man called Nikolai you of
Florence once said my quote other things
can be compensated for but if an error
is made in war there is no way to repair
it the loss of honor is permanent
resulting in death and destruction Tom
seems pretty anodyne could be a little
reference not to the prince or the
discourses but perhaps to Machiavelli's
art of war but actually looking very
closely at his text at various other
points in time including in the in the
there are actually passages which are
very curiously seem to be almost
directly taken from the preface to the
press in self-presentation
and in various other kinds of ways so
what we actually get is a bit of a
puzzle then where the Jesuit author best
known for his moralizing Christian texts
which often had exactly the opposite
effect to that which he intended when
he's put to the task of producing this
mirror for princes produces the text
which again remains incredibly
ambivalent in its effects and perhaps
even equally ambivalent in its
intentions because whether he wished it
or not we could say that some traces of
the order and perhaps even of the words
of the Florentine managed to slip their
way 100 in one fashion or another
through the cracks thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much for this incredibly
informative and fascinating yeah
discussion about how these two as
cultures actually interacted with the
Portuguese European and the mobile
Persian what seems to me is rather
interesting here is that what was the
motive in the first place for join years
who asked for the production of a
miracle princess in the European
tradition is this obviously its must
have had some example of that in the
mobile courts a number of them
presumably were written for him is this
some kind of a comparative study of
methods of rule and culture of kingship
that we witness and whether we know
anything about the impact of this text
whether if there is a very famous
history as probably I'm sure yourself
and some people in the audience might
know that in the 19th century when the
Pasha of Egypt Mohammed Ali was
presented with vaca valleys text and was
proposed to him that it should be
translated and published and block a
printing house he somewhat paused and
suggested that much of what what he
really has said from the material that
was presented to him is already very
well known to us so there is no need for
for the translation of this text is this
some kind of say in the mobile court
some kind of an understanding that
indeed this tradition of kingship in the
European context is pretty similar or
parallel or a great contrast to the
ideas of kingship as it appears in the
political calls
the miracle princes well first of all
let me say that a problem as is often
the case is the reception history of
these texts is very very difficult to
actually get ones ones hands on I mean
one of the great things about that that
modulus is jahangiri of the sitar is
that it's one of the rare instances
where we can actually see from somebody
else's point of view because you know
the the Jesuits always tell us we
brought out this this icon and people
fell on the floor and began praying and
so on and so forth but I mean you
actually see a situation where these
guys are giving you a completely
different notion of how people are
looking at it making fun of it up
pulling at it in this way or another
pointing to its internal contradictions
we got to this text we actually cannot
put our finger on the reception history
but let me point something else out to
you which is an interesting point which
is a which is a much larger and
difficult issue which is this that I
pointed to you that the models had a
clear notion of the in Assyrian and
various other traditions coming out of
the Arab lands out of Iran out of
Central Asia and this was very much a
part of their library of course what is
interesting is that exactly at the same
time the mullahs are also quite
interested in what you could think of is
the Indyk political traditions right so
for instance they are interested in
translating Indyk texts which also have
quote unquote political wisdom in them
right so for instance there are chunks
of let's say particularly the
Mahabharata which they've translated as
the residue nama which contain very
clear discussions of of ethics of
political strategy etc etc I mean there
is of course that famous episode coming
towards the end where this kind of elder
statesman is on his deathbed and he
gives wisdom to thee to the generations
generations to come so in fact the
mobile code is interesting in the sense
that is it's really at the confluence of
the meeting point of different
traditions of political of political
thinking and in the indian vernaculars
we have what is sometimes called and
I've written about this elsewhere with
with filter of Nara and rock neeti which
is a kind of an indigenous political
wisdom of some kind or another and we
can actually see that for the Mughals
these were all potentially bodies of
materials which were to be which were to
be drawn upon so from that point of view
without my actually being able to say
here is a foreman or a letter from
Jahangir where he says I want you to
tell me this this and this well good
guess well enough what he had in mind
what he probably would not have been
able to figure out but again it's very
interesting see because I was puzzled in
the beginning by the fact that this man
keeps using this very strange mix of
chronology he goes back to the Romans he
mentions the Greek sometimes he has
chunks on the Byzantines
then he comes to Portugal and Spain in
the 15th and 16th century and so on and
I was thinking about this and discussing
with this with some of my friends who
work on on similar texts in Europe in
this I put this is exactly what
Machiavelli does he also jumps
chronologically all over the place he
uses a lot of ancient examples so in
that sense let's say I think the
interest of the text is that it's highly
unlikely to me that jungle would have
you know micromanagement it seems much
more likely here that he would have
given a sort of general set of of
indications and then it would really
have been the kind of materials first of
all what he could do and I suppose it's
past a little bit of function of way
after what what say we had in his
library at that point in fact I must
mention by the way that he invented one
thing which is that they has a long
section which gives a so-called advice
text from mecaenas to Augustus my
colleagues were specialists of the roman
empire tells me no such tax exists and
that he made it up
thank you again for very interesting
talk two questions in the Indic context
will would the Mughal library and court
would have had access to earth Shastra
Arthur no no okay let's be clear about
one thing you know there's a problem
with the transmission of the Sahara
which you've probably Breyer well
because you know that was lost as we
have it today was found in a very small
number of copies in the early 20th
century but you know again it is
something which I've discussed it with
Nara and Roy elsewhere there is a
tradition which is kept alive which is
not of the Sahara as such but it's so
you will often find people mentioning
what they call channel donítí or China
candy-coat ilium as an idea and this is
this fairly common in medieval times so
what is really retained in a way is the
notion of an attitude but but suddenly
it's not one of the texts that was
either available to them quad texts or
suddenly it was never translated going
back to Mecca Valley I guess if the
Jesuits had were reluctant to bring
Machiavelli to Jangi they probably had
even less reason to introduce him to
Makaveli splay Lamine dragula which with
us all its anti-clerical tone and
substance of it so I suppose in these
writings there is there is nothing about
Mecca where these plays and other things
like that
no but actually again let me come point
something out to you okay
if you want to Jesuit I mean for example
there is a mirror of princess text
written by Erasmus
it's an incredibly boring text it's very
sententious and very boring
they could've translated that they could
have given him some version of that you
know it also someone something which was
drawn upon I mean but your Ricci
translated bits of Erasmus on friendship
into Chinese for the for the Ming
Emperor but here it seems to me that
they seem to be torn because there seems
to be they don't want to explicitly say
they're doing it but there are passages
as I said off the introduction which are
literally so close to passages of the
preface of of the prince that you really
wonder what this man is playing at so
you get the feeling is sort of being
really coy with it he's giving off a
little bits of it and I said that coded
reference to Nikolaj you of Florence
he's doing this and then he's also not
doing it right but suddenly the the
clerical question and so on and so forth
is not is not at all of the ciphers
thank you very much so maybe staying
with your last comments about
Machiavelli I wanted to ask you I'm
still mulling over this of your
provocation but what is exactly the
boomerang effect of this severe nephews
back to the scholarship on Machiavelli
because that's one of the purposes of
your connected history has to come and
hunt what we know about European history
as much as everything else so two rather
uncontroversial things about
Machiavelli's one is that the prince
breaks away completely with the previous
tradition of the mirror of the princess
and the other one is that Machiavellian
Machiavellian is more completely
different than Machiavelli I mean
there's still debate on chapter
twenty-fifth but he had a very naive and
hopeful feeling and that he was made
into Machiavellianism right and so these
are two questions that seems to you know
haunt us in your present
I mean your severe nephew takes
Machiavelli as literally as a mirror too
as a book of advice in a very literal
sense in which he probably wasn't meant
to be or in a you know complicated way
and it makes him it makes the advice he
said that's a I'm not sure how to
formulate it but you know is he may he's
he turning Machiavelli into
machiavellianism or is he still closer
to that earlier perhaps short-lived
tradition of living of reading
Machiavelli as Machiavellian taking him
in a more constructive pedagogical naive
of fashion I mean what were what are we
have to take away for for for for the
scholarship and the European is
diversion of what we know about
Machiavelli from how this particular
reading was done at the time so you'd be
aware of the fact of course that you
know in the Iberian context you know
basically 1620s they with the with the
kind of big push to for Rahsaan de
estado as a concept where what they're
doing is of course claiming to reread
other classical authors so you know
whole series of some of whom were
actually Jesuits themselves but some of
whom are not Jesuits are you know
writing these texts which are actually
leading us in the direction of what you
correctly referred to as
Machiavellianism because la santé estado
eventually becomes that right but I
think that this is this is in fact short
of it because I don't think that he has
I think that he's in a situation of
intellectual isolation
and I think that he's providing us a
relatively naive specific reading that
he has from what his memories are of
having read Machiavelli when he was
being educated so it's actually to my
mind closer to that spirit than to
eventually what would be recognizable by
the middle of the 17th century let us
say as as as a full-fledged
machiavellianism it's actually for me
therefore the really interesting thing
is how I sent almost that despite
himself almost he's he's he's pulled
into he's attracted by this idea of of
using this this this text but other
texts much more than having elevated it
to some sort of a very broad ideological
standpoint from which he can he can he
can function which incidentally is not
the you know hydrological standpoint of
Savior in general at all if you read his
other materials for instance there's
this small text probably written by him
on the mobile part Ravagers flourish
published not so long ago if you read it
it's really I mean you can nothing could
be further from a Machiavellian spirit
than that text so I would actually think
of him as being much closer in a sense
to naive reader paths then closer you
might say to the spirit of the author
and to what he became a century
afterwards of more than a century
afterwards yeah
thank you this is radium method logical
question because I think we all struggle
with it you know some working on Safavid
Iran I have my Pietro della valleys and
the ODI aces and others who won't take
their shoes off to go into a mosque for
example right so they draw a very strict
boundaries they won't drink the wine
because it hasn't been watered down
right so they have very strict
boundaries that they draw between us and
them and when I was looking at and I
don't and I want to know a little bit
more about what's going on in the mobile
case and I was thinking of the two
images you showed one of the acronym ah
in you know the sort of gathering of the
yeah of the above so called a vodka
right exactly this one exactly where we
have the port the jesuits there and then
a subsequent image in which we saw you
know they seem to be one amongst all the
others you have the sort of clerics the
Hindus and so on and here in this case
where he's really pulled out the Jesuit
figures in the history of the Muslims
and yet not right he sort of looked at
distinct and I wanted to ask you how do
we use these sources in a way how do we
use their voices I mean we need the
abscissa ties we need the text we need
the translations in a way to naturalize
them into the histories of the mullahs
and the same with it you know Francesca
you're having a difficult time
naturalizing it back or taking it back
perhaps into the histories of Europe
where do we fit these figures in because
by by their own nature by their own
displacement their liminal they really
defy being naturalized because they are
themselves sort of on the edges of
identities on the edge the experimental
figures by definition so how do we how
do we really start to use them or can we
not should we just say the we kind you
know I mean first of all I let's let's
also be clear about the fact that there
are people in the same boat with us now
so I mean for instance if you I find
very interesting to see the evolution of
the historiography and Matthew Ritchie
all right
to which
distinguished former members of this
university have have contributed but if
you actually read the last lot of of
writings and I'm particularly thinking
of the excellent book with a bad title
by Ronnie Pasha because he talks about
what is it Jesuit in the forbidden city
was ever in the forbidden city actually
so it's a bit of a misnomer you can
actually see what Russia is doing there
is actually giving you a very very
different sense of Ricci than the Ricci
that we used to know a generation ago
all right and and a very different sense
of the nature of those exchanges of
those of those those the intellectual
context of that late mink coat and then
what what we used to have and I think
that we are in a way in that and
precisely that that same situation over
there and in fact it's you know it's I
would actually say I mean if you push me
to it that you see I mean this is the
current struggle which is going on sorry
let me find it because if you need this
book write this book still represents
that old tradition you know where the
person who's a front and center only the
only person who has any agency
whatsoever is in this affairs area right
and and basically everybody else's is a
fest from it he never asks the basic
question of you know how is it that
Xavier who I mean you know that in the
majolica January there are these various
moments in which in which Xavier says
something and then Jahangir says I don't
understand this guys punish him and so
then then of the cidade has to step in
and translate his version into passion
and and and and he could he he he at one
point he says I like excuse excuse the
Padre for his come Danny she that is
Ivana Farsi so now to imagine from that
point of view that this man is then you
know in rhetorical control of this text
a little bit absurd right so I do think
that you know once we actually think
about that and then we actually
reintroduce this idea that these are all
quarter texts but go ahead in very
different ways clearly right I lied and
have it as an experience course and I
can tell you that it's not a good idea
to try to take a text and separate it
and attribute this word to this person
and that word or that sentence to that
person right but you can still see how
in each of these texts this whole
business of the collaboration plays
itself out in so many different kinds of
of ways right and so there I think we
are we are onto something in terms of
actually figuring out water and
intellectual interaction looks like
where you cannot say I know I'm going to
stay on the other side of the threshold
because you have air across the
threshold and you are in the business of
writing a text together thank you so
much my question is about the reception
of day of the book how was how was it
received by its readership because the
kind of the morality that he's trying to
promote is they is very different from
the from the type of of advices that for
example Nasia tena to see has in his
logano City so uh where the king was the
King for example shot by or I mean how
was how he received the book and you
know that's precisely the problem that I
that I don't think that the probe we
don't actually have a moment when
because he's in the jungle nama for
instance Jong he never talks about how
they came we presented him with this
book and he read it and he thought this
or that about it he doesn't say anything
to us about that okay um now I mean I
recently was presenting a version of
this talk in Emery and a large number of
indulgence there and of course I mean to
come back to your question
I mean their response to me was to say I
mean this is good stuff you should read
Co Thalia I mean that if you want to
know what real you know vicious politics
is I mean look at that oh you know for
that matter I mean I mentioned the
Mahabharata which did you I mean that
terrible episodes in the Mahabharata
where the so-called good guys are doing
unbelievably nasty things you know so in
some sense you see this is the
interesting question which is because
the problem is that the genre the genre
is the mirror of the prince yes and for
example in the common examples of that
in Persian is Abu stomach you never find
such a story in Abu Salam a and he never
tries to for example the author never
tries to promote a Treasury or can
concede or those kinds of bad habits and
yeah but first of all let me just make a
small formal point which is that he's
not actually following very closely in
the formal construction of the text the
tradition of the mirror of princess
because the typical Indo Persian mirror
of princes is not built on an edifice of
exemplar that's all not how its best so
you don't actually go from one exemplar
to another to another with each one
giving you something they are set up
schematically very very differently they
often are constructed at a much higher
level of abstraction and so in some
sense you can see that formally he's
departing from any other received mirror
of princess texts that would have been
around in the mughal court this looks
sort of like them but it's not really
like that this might look primitive but
the language of the discussions which
they had
it was a Farsi therefore the Jesuit were
really in disadvantage therefore it was
not a level playing field it was not
therefore how this problem of unleveled
situation have been overcome or they try
to make it more level yeah you can see
that various solutions were tried but by
the way you know the for everyone it was
a not a level playing field
you know when the English ambassador Sir
Thomas Roe comes to the Mughal Court
little later
I mean his problem is that he the only
way that he can communicate with the
Mughals is by using the Jesuits and that
this is an absurd situation where the
Jesuits were sworn enemies are also
supposed to be his translators right and
and we know that we know because Thomas
Rowe was associated with Walter Raleigh
and he had fought to some extent in
South America he spoke a bit of Spanish
so he used to try to speak bad Spanish
and then the Jesuits would claim that
they were translating his bad Spanish
into whatever kind of Farsi they knew
and and you can see an even more not
level not level playing field but you
see the whole problem is this that
eventually everyone's dream is to is to
abolish the intermediary right and and
to somehow make it that because the
intermediate is always the untrust
untrustworthy person but eventually this
will it's an impossible dream even
Xavier who claimed that is his knowledge
of Persian was superior to to those of
many others it was very far from being
able to do it and but that's the very
nature of the game right it's a very
nature of the game that you're placing
yourself in precisely that that position
and you are convinced that somehow the
power of what you're saying is so great
that you can overcome that lack of a
level playing field
well I hope you wouldn't mind if I
thanked second question for you actually
going back to the earlier part of your
talk about the actual text that whether
it was the story of Jesus that does
Dunham I see that was produced and so
forth yes this one the deception of that
I do very briefly pointed out in Safavid
Iran was very different a number of
refutations were produced in or
libidinal ad is very famous for most
colorful and the number of other words
these are very in a sense for me is
rather remarkable because they were
produced right around the time 16 2016
22 actually when the Portuguese were
expelled from the Persian Gulf and it
has obviously a very significant
political subtext I wondered whether you
referred earlier on to Tophet on
Mujahideen's
I wonder whether the texts that were
produced in Mobile India had the same
kind of a political significance or in
their tone of refuting the Christian
texts whether they would fall back on
the religious tradition of a mobile a
court or whether you would see a
different approach because in the case
of the Safavids is clearly Shiite
approach and they relied remarkably on
the gtex
although even in the early ones if I
recall from my reading of this text many
years ago they were also an appeal to
the Jewish communities in Isfahan in
order to raise question with regard to
the narratives that are produced by by
the Jesuits to them yes so I certainly
this was the case in the later time but
even I think in the Safavieh period that
was the case I wonder whether you would
see such a nuance in the text that you
that you came across in the mobile court
no in fact the curious thing of course
is that while people
Amyx came about in the Safavid context
you don't find those those polemical
texts in the Moodle course in the 17th
century I mean you find elements of that
polemic in and of the satar's account of
the discussions but you don't actually
find a production of such political text
there's um
I mean I've written about this elsewhere
but there is um you know a number of
different sort of accounts scattered
here and there of the Europeans in the
Moodle chronicles I mean perhaps the
most extensive one is in the text
actually by a person of Iranian origin
title Muhammad's observe re Co here in
the text called Rosa to Tajin where he
talks to
he describes the Portuguese and their
presence in Bengal as well as in Goa he
was actually the ambassador of the
models to Goa for a short while he even
has an account a short account of the
history of Portugal but it's it's it's a
little Manor in a relatively in a
relatively flat tone I mean he says some
not very nice things about the
Portuguese he says it there very dirty
and the day they don't have proper
toilet practices let's say it'll didn't
wash as they should but in general you
know this doesn't amount to a
full-fledged you know polemic of the
types that you find in this Arabic
literature coming out of the coast it's
a turtle which I think it's part of a
group of four or five Texans another
text called Fatima bean which is a text
in verse there are also some other
Arabic text which is now slowly people
are starting to analyze sometimes of
theological nature of the need for jihad
against the Portuguese and so on so
that's the but the Moghuls tradition I
would say doesn't bother to really take
on this thing which in a way it should
have been a terrible disappointment to
these people because it means in the
sense that here you are you've produced
all these things the models find it
interesting enough to have some
illustrate
manuscripts of it and so on but in a way
you are relegated to a you know the the
rank of of curiosities you know so a UK
you put these this is all part of a
Giles arrived you know
wonders and curiosities it's not as
people who are posing some kind of
existential problem for you which of
course would be the case in the
nineteenth century you know and in the
nineteenth century it becomes it becomes
something of a quite different order and
then when you have them when as there
are these debates and so on that creates
a whole whole other other atmosphere so
in so in a certain sense I mean coming
back to the to the reception question
which has been which has been asked it's
quite curious to see that that the the I
mean one even wonder sometimes whether
you know xavier by 1609 was thinking you
know okay all this religious stuff I've
written I've not been able to penetrate
now let me try something else to know so
he may have been you know eager to
accept that invitation as a at least
another way of somehow trying to get
through because he he was you know
possibly aware of the fact that I mean
you know it's around this time that they
stopped this business which they used to
claim every year they used to write back
and say the king is thinking of
converting he's going to become a
Christian you know of course looking
never becomes a Christian thanks very
much for your talk every leg the
intellectual history provided and all
these individuals ever brought up but I
was wondering if it's possible at all to
have any kind of institutional history
of this intellectual history and these
individuals and what I mean by that it
seems that across the reigns of various
mobile Emperor's there seems to be some
kind of interest preserved and a
translation project or historiography
which doubles as political Tory a sort
of political self-fashioning or self
reflexivity
so are there intellectual circles within
courts which can counter some kind
institutional body are there
other institutions educational or
otherwise which overlapped with the
court but also have an existence outside
which preserve this possibility and this
interest in both indict X but also texts
coming from elsewhere and I think this
brings little broader question of what
is this what is unique about a big early
modern Imperial state like the Mughals
and how do they compare to other early
modern Imperial states which add various
at heights of you know imperial
expansion also become deeply interested
in the historiography of other empires
and I suppose another way of thinking
about that would be what's happening in
the Deccan techne States I've just at
the same time or around the time of
Mughal expansion into the south are
there portuguese figures or other
itinerate european figures who are also
providing similar texts or trying to
participate in the circulation of
similar knowledge and so I suppose it's
a way of asking whether big Imperial
states have a distinct kind of early
modernity from smaller states or not and
sort of maybe asking for a question
about structural causes of such
knowledge projects so sorry if that's
tough I mean I think that it's what it's
worth stressing that there is something
distinctive about the Mughals in
relation to some of the smaller states
that neighbor them it's not the case for
example did you find such a sustained
interest or such a sustained set of
interactions in the case of the of the
Deccan so let's the Jesuits come and go
a little bit
they never established much of a
presence you don't find this kind of
ongoing dealing now with regard to the
to the Mughals you know we have now over
the last good number of years a fairly
decent historiography with regard to for
instance the Mughals and and what you
could probably call Indyk knowledge
right so a lot of it is is sort of
summed up in for instance the book of
Audrey Trischka and on on sans written
back in the Mughal Court but it goes
back to people like pick array and and
paul Dundas and various people had
written about it so we know there were
people both in the court and outside the
court who functioning to
provide this sort of intellectual
mediation so it meant that there were
people who were learning Sanskrit or
certainly we're learning enough Sanskrit
to work with people who really knew
Sanskrit right we know that there were
traditions amongst the gens of people
coming out of specific monasteries who
actually learnt enough Persian to
function in the in the two directions
and then we know the Dever of course
increasing numbers of first of both
brahmins and then of course increasingly
as you get into the seventies a student
this is something which I've written
about it some length with muzaffer alum
these traditions of guys and happily
families and and the first students
Rajiv kindred wrote about this at at
book length but you can actually see
that there are familiar with traditions
of people who become these kind of
service people who who understand their
role as functioning in these two
different language and cultural milieu
right so when you get to someone like so
genre Bhandari at the end of the 17th
century this is a guy who can actually
read the Indyk tradition and put it into
Persian in a text like philosophy and so
on and try to reconcile and and by the
way and wind up therefore facing
non-trivial problems and just mentioned
something to you that very few people
adequately in the Western intellectual
history tradition realize that by the
early 17th century the Muslims in in
India were facing the pre-adamite
problem because they are essentially
come into contact the traditions which
were giving them much much longer
chronology of the creation of the world
than anything which the Christian
tradition or the Muslim tradition was
willing to admit and then there was a
question of what you do with that land
knowledge or I mean do you dismiss it do
you actually make sense of it etc so in
fact I mean the pre-adamite question is
posed even by Farish there in the
beginning of his office his Chronicle
right and it's it's both viable frazzle
it's posed by so genre and so on so
there's there's there's not with regard
to knowledge concerning the
you're up it's it's harder to figure it
out you know because we have these
little specific vignettes okay so you
know everybody who knows anything about
mother history knows about
Daanish Mongkok right garnishment on who
was this this Iranian who became first
of all beignets and employer and who got
there to translate they capped and guess
on the into portion for her right but
the thing is that he was not a one-off
figure there's a there's a million from
which from which this comes and we know
that there are other people I mean for
instance if you read some of Betty's
unpublished letters you know he talks
about the people who's the best informed
in the middle code about Europe and he
talks about people who for instance who
have a good level of Latin in the mughal
court of the sitar had a decent level of
latin by the way and i'm clearly there
are you know such such characters
whether you can track them and say these
actually families where this knowledge
is being transmitted from one generation
to another it's still a bit difficult to
say i just close with that you're my
response little anecdote teachers you
know when when william norris who is the
new East India Company's representative
to the mother of court shows up in the
court and then he tries to X to the
Mughal situm explain the political
geography of Europe to us right so then
he stops and then they said to him so
you represent the King of England now
you claim that the King of England is
bigger than the King of France and he
says yes that we said and what tell me
why is the King of England actually the
king of Holland I thought you were
enemies he says oh well it's a
complicated story install so and then he
realizes little by little that actually
they're leading him up the garden pot
and they know a lot about the specific
history of political history of Europe
in the previous 20 years which they're
not loving on turn the day they actually
know right and so there's that the even
a translated version of the document
which he brings back questions for the
ambassador of the king of the hat
wearers right and you can see all that
data management and clearly there is
transmitted knowledge
inside the Mughal Court which which is
which is kept now we are not yet at the
point where we can you know give a as
convincing an account as we can of the
people who did the Sanskrit mediation
all the people who who did the mediation
with some of the other vernacular
traditions but it's not impossible I
think it's certainly a task which
somebody could set themselves for so
synonymous I'm a I'm again fascinating
lecture and I wanted to ask you actually
a long dear a question as to whether a
case like this provides there any
evidence for significant changes that
are happening not only in the mirror for
Prince's genre itself but also in the
notions of statecraft
specifically to relate that to Salim as
question to the ethical principles that
actually underlie statecraft and and how
this question actually came to me is
when you're discussing Jesuits producing
the mirror for Prince's and that too
reacting any overtly elliptic Christian
or biblical references from it I was in
fact reminded of my own work in the 18th
and 19th centuries where in which Allah
Monceau fees are producing a vast body
of literature none of which is actually
mirror for Prince's in fact they're very
particularly keeping themselves away
from that from that domain so it's
actually curious that is there something
that that's actually new that's
happening here in the sense that we're
trying to find new ethical premises for
what constitutes statecraft or
redefining ethics to create a kind of
system of of good governance which may
have a very different relationship let's
say with the nizam al-mulk or joiny
mirror for Prince's tradition of a of an
earlier ulema age yeah I mean it's an
interesting question it in fact it's a
question you might say that was offer
imposes for himself in that in that book
on political Islam he is um in a way
more interested in showing the the
creative ways in which continuities can
be massaged to to work with with
specific
circumstances and sometimes there are
disconcerting things that show up you
know for example when he found reading
this text which acts like a diary that
actually this text is very largely
simply lifted from a text called a clock
a hajima written for mr. Mohammed Hakeem
the half-brother of Edward in what is
considered to be the gray very
conservative court of of Kabul in the
1570s and early 1580s
but this apparently Texan move from this
context to this other context without
having to suffer an enormous amount of
of change so the one way of looking at
it is I mean I would say there is a
broadly sort of an a problem which you
always face in Indian history which is
that you know if you if you if you're
looking for signs of very radical
rupture where let's say you're looking
for something like X genre is abolished
or no one talks about this anymore and
we'll only talk about something else
it seems very rarely to be the case
because actually what seems to happen
rather is that you get an accumulation
so that it's not as if the you know the
older tradition disappears the older
tradition continues in some form and
then the real difficulty is is measuring
up the bits and pieces that exist and
coming to some kind of conclusion on how
one balances out you know the net effect
of the coexistence of all of these these
various things so in a sense you could
say well you look at Johnny's cotton you
actually look at the panoply of possible
things that he had which could be called
mirror of princes advice literature and
so on I mean it represents really is a
vast array of of possible of possible
position some of which are very very
close to I mean for example I think it
was perhaps Professor Saigon or someone
who pointed out that the text
that you know Sajal we edited the Moyes
idea hangry that's actually almost
verbatim taken from text from a couple
of centuries earlier
so it's he just he's just taken it and
fiddled it he says he wrote it in three
days that's not very surprising and and
so it's really a cut and paste job
mostly with a new dedication and a
couple of frills alright so you can
actually see the the the actual
reproduction of and and indeed you know
the interesting thing is that if you if
you're writing a text at a certain level
of abstraction from concrete
circumstances I mean you're much happier
with that when you're dealing with
making the text pass transhistorical e
right so so in that sense I mean I would
say that the the way of searching for
new nests you might say has to be a
little bit different from assuming that
what it means is that you have got rid
of the old
[Applause]
[Music]